chad is with us in Billings Montana hi
Chad how are you I'm doing all right how
are you David better than I deserve
what's up well I was calling I wanted to
get your opinion we moved here to
Billings in June of 2017 we purchased
the home we currently go about two
hundred and eighty thousand dollars on
the home we started we had a few rooms
painted when we moved in and we started
noticing some large cracks and some
doors that wouldn't shut so we had an
engineer come out come back out and we
bought the home we had an engineer check
the foundation he said everything was ok
it's about a ten-year-old home this
engineer that came out it was this last
November he's asked the meeting that
there's between 40 to $80,000 of
foundational repair that the home
requires and I am just kind of baffled
as to what to do at this point the home
was near the top of our price range and
I certainly don't have 40 to $80,000 to
sink into a home that we just bought a
year and a half ago okay so which of
these guys is wrong because a foundation
did not cave in in 14 months since
you've owned this house yeah so the the
one that came out he believes in and
there's some pieces to this but he
believes that the original engineer that
came out with some things and that the
prior homeowners may have covered up
some cracks but he couldn't say for sure
there was any reports that were done on
the actual home at the time besides our
engineer just telling our realtor that
everything was okay mm-hmm so he was
functioning as a home inspector you know
after a home inspection as well so he
had the home inspection and the engineer
so we thought we did all everything we
needed to to make sure we were you know
in good shape okay there's one of two
things going on and I don't know which
it is and you're gonna have to get to
the bottom of it and figure it out okay
one is the new engineer is right and you
completely got screwed in which case the
other engineer the realtor and the
homeowner about to get sued
and okay because they covered this up if
it's so dramatic that there's $80,000
worth of foundation repair 14 months
after you own it unless it just was over
the top of a dad-blame sinkhole that's
somebody hid something like a lot of
people hit something with their
incompetence or just straight-out hit it
okay which makes them liable in your
state and so you'd need to seek an
attorney's advice if that's the case or
the second possibility is that the new
engineer is a drama queen and is playing
this up to be a whole lot bigger mess
than it really is and and so what we
need is a third opinion for sure on what
is really going on here because I'll
tell you man I own a bunch of real
estate I've owned 2,000 properties in my
life I have seen some bad foundations
lots of them and it's like termite
damage you know most of the time there's
hyperbole and drama around it in excess
of what it really takes to fix it and
people people just there's something
about it that they just go bananas and I
mean I would be shocked if you really
have $80,000 worth of problems that you
wouldn't have visually seen that
yourself walking through the house
before you bought it
and that's part of the trick in the
story I do have some things in the newer
engineer the the neighborhood that were
in unfortunately there's a number of
homes experiencing some where issues
part of the trick with ours was we
thought these are newer homes that are
having issues we thought ours being a 10
year old home and that we had an
engineer and that we thought okay it's
gonna move it Dennis movies okay real
well what's your needs in it you need a
third opinion and you need the and you
need to get some legal counsel you need
to talk to an attorney
because if you've got a thing that's
been hidden from you then solar
disclosure laws are going to get them